>> All right, Jon, can you start off by telling
us a little bit about your company and product?
>> KRAGH: Sure, I'm Jon Kragh. I'm the creator
of vastrank.com, that's V-A-S-T, rank.com.
It's a college rating and review website.
It's all of the content. It's user-generated.
So people come to the site and they'll find
a college or a trade school or anything that
they've attended and so forth. And they'll
actually create a user review. And basically
is that I've come up with college rankings
based on the user reviews. And so, no longer
are the college ratings on the site based
on professional reviews but it's all based
on user-generated content and something that
the way that the Web is going now with reviews
in general. And so, that's basically the best
ranking in a nutshell. It has some other unique
features that were developed and it's the
reason that I'm out here at Google I/O and
showcasing one of the sessions that I did.
>> All right, so what Google development platforms
are you leveraging?
>> KRAGH: And so, I'm using the--first I'm
using the Maps API. And so, at Vast Rank,
if you go to Vast Rank and you click on the
Map Tab it's something that we call the Ranking
Map. And what it is, is that depending on
what the user has in view and what the, what
the right criteria that they choose it will
show you the top-ranked schools or whatever
the user has in view. And so, for example,
you can zoom in on just the San Francisco
area. And it will show you the top-ranked
schools. And if you will pick like academics
it will show you the top-ranked schools for
academics but then you can choose any of the
ratings that users will potentially rate the
college on the Vast Rank. It's completely
dynamic so you can take the map and you could
scroll over and you see like the East Coast
and you could see the top-ranked schools and
it's so instantaneous. And so, I use the Maps
API for that. And then I use the language,
the languages API in order to do translations.
And so, basically when a user comes to Vast
Rank and their browser is set to a different
language other than English on the fly I use
the Google translation APIs to translate the
user-generated content. Again, the best-ranked
is centered around user or user-generated
content. And so, that's the most important
element. And so, it was a perfect fit for
the translation APIs because when a user comes
to the site, let's say for German I'll detect
that on the server site and emit some JavaScript
to call the Google APIs to translate that
content for the German user. And actually
at the conference today I've had a few bilingual
users that came to the booth and they were
spotting checking things and they were like,
"This is pretty good." And so, I'm really
happy with that. Client locations and other
API that I'm using that's just available to
you off of the AJAX loader, and so, it's basically
a way to try to find out geographically where
the user is located and it's based off of
the IP. And the keynote at IL they talked
about integrating--making client location
better. They used some other methods but right
now it's available via the AJAX API. You can
actually get a location. And what I use for
that is two aspects, when you bring up the
ranking you have a choice to set on the map
where you are which is just like a really
simple use case for that. But also Vast Rank
has a personalization section which it suggests
colleges to you and it's on the right hand
side and like as you're browsing through the
site. And as you browse through the site it
gives an idea of the colleges and the things
that you're looking at. And then I come up
with--based on historical data I kind of take
what you're looking and look at what other
users have looked at that you looked at and
come up with things that I might want to suggest
to you that are interesting. And using client
location I can take those things that I'm
going to potentially suggest to the user.
And I can actually say, "Okay, I have this
set of suggestion--possible suggestions, let
me break it down by client location and distance
to these colleges that I'm going to suggest
and then I present those geographically targeted
suggestions to the user. And so, a lot of
the AJAX APIs that I'm using, mostly using,
I'm also using the geo-coding APIs to geo-code
the colleges and so forth. And then ahead
of time and then on the ranking map itself
you have like a little center map function
which is the functionality. It's just like
using a Google local or a Google Maps now.
And so, if you just enter in any particular
text or you can click Center Map it will center
on the map. And so, I'm using quite a few
of the APIs actually on Vast Rank.
>> And so, what made you decide to use the
maps and API?
>> KRAGH: Well, originally, I spoke about
this a little bit in the session that I had
at I/O. But the original vision for Vast Rank
was that every college would have a profile
and then what's the interesting thing on profiles
and social networking sites. One of the most
interesting aspects is the profile picture.
And for me being a developer at that time
I knew Google Maps was cool and it's something
that I wanted to play with and it was about
a year and half ago when I started to think
about this. And I didn't have a profile picture
for each college, right? And so, it was hard
enough putting the data together for all the
colleges but what I needed to do was come
up with something to put in place of the profile
picture. And so, I started to play with Maps
just that it was an evolution I would say
that I'm going to put the Google Map there
and then I had it in a high moment because
I had all these colleges and numbering and
so forth and that evolved into the ranking
map. And so each profile where normally users
picture would on a--like a MySpace or Facebook
or any other social networking site. That's
why I put the Google Map and that's how I
got started with it. And so, it was never
like some great idea that I had. In the beginning
it was an evolution, you know, of trying things
and experimenting and so forth.
>> Very cool. And so, outside of what you
talked about what are some other benefits
that you've done in using Google APIs.
>> KRAGH: Really the biggest benefit of the
Google APIs is they provide you these awesome
capabilities like the client location for
instance and translation but they are dead
simple, right? And so like, when I did my
session, the session was more about the concepts
of creative ways to use the APIs because,
really, when you're calling the APIs, they're
so simple. And like translating you're basically
passing a chunk of text. You're passing--here's
the source language at its end and here's
the target language at its end. And so, and
then you get a result back for a client location
and for the client geo-coding and the client
location and so forth. Those are just like
one method going on and so forth. And so,
really, the real benefit of the Google APIs
is they're just clean, they often use this
like simple, these things that are relatively
simple functionally-wise you would think.
But you can expand, you can expand on those
ideas and use them in creative ways and think
about your own business solution or whatever
you might be developing. And the API just
stays out of your way. For me, the API is
simply you read the documentation once and
you just go through an experiment and it's
like dead simple, you know. And so, that's
the biggest benefit that I've seen.
>> And so, it sounds like it has reduced the
amount of work that you've done?
>> KRAGH: Oh, tremendously, yeah. I mean,
oftentimes in one line of code you're getting
like translation site. I'm adding translating
content on my site. I put it together in 40
minutes literally. And so, it's been--it saved
a tremendous amount of work.
>> And so, what kinds of features were made
possible by having access to the Google API?
>> KRAGH: You know, just the ones I have gone
over so far, you know, like internalization
of content and something that would have--if
I had to go other to other on the news it
would have much more difficult to international--to
translate all the content. And then the ranking
map which is like completely driven off of
it. If I didn't have the mapping technology
in the API with that I would never have been
able to develop the ranking map and so forth.
And personalization which is like a real key
aspect that I really find interesting and
that has a real high value to users being
able to geographically target suggestions
and so forth to make their experience better.
I mean, to be able to do that on one line
of code to get to their location and so forth,
all those features would have not been possible
had it not been for the Google APIs.
>> Well, Jon, I want to thank you for your
time today.
>> KRAGH: Cool. Cool. Thank you so much.